[موسيقى]
تحيه لكم اعزائي المشاهدين هذه نشره
التاسعه يقدمها لكم هذا المساء صهيب شراير
نبدا بالعناوين
ثماني دول في اوبك بلس تقرر خفضا طوعيا
باكثر من مليون و600 الف برميل يوميا بدءا
من مايو
مقتل مراسل حربي واصابه 25 شخصا في انفجار
مقهى بسام بطرسب بعبوه ناسفه في تمثال
نيويورك تستعد امنيا لمحكمه ترامب
الثلاثاء والاخير يتحدث علنا قبل مثوله
امام المحكمه
دراما الحرب والحب تفاصيل تاريخ مقاومه
العثمانيين في الجزيره العربيه
[موسيقى]
في خطوه احترازيه لدعم استقرار اسواق
الطاقه عالميا اعلنت عده دول في تحالف
اوبك بلس اليوم خفض انتاجها باكثر من
مليون ونصف المليون برميل يوميا حتى نهايه
العام
[موسيقى]
اذا للمزيد حول اول ملفات التاسعه هذا
المساء قرار هذه الدول في خفضه انتاجها
حتى نهايه العام معنا الزميل ناصر الطيبي
وهذه التغطيه الخاصه في قسم الاقتصاد من
العربيه ناصر مساء الخير اهلا بك قرار مهم
من حيث الشكل ومن حيث التوقيت كذلك بالفعل
صهيب من حيث الشكل بانه سمعنا ثمان
اعلانات من ثماني دول عن خفض انتاج طوعي
في 12 دقيقه فقط والتوقيت سنتحدث عنه اكثر
صهيب خلال التغطيه نتابع التفاصيل معك
تفضل ناصر
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا في اثني عشر دقيقه ثماني دول
من اوبك بلس تعلن عن سلسله تخفيضات طوعيه
في الانتاج حيث قادت السعوديه خفضا طوعيا
منسقا للانتاج النفطي من دول داخل اوبك
وخارجها باجمالي يفوق المليون ونصف
المليون برميل يوميا بدءا من مايو وحتى
نهايه العام الجاري يضاف لها طبعا ما
اعلنته روسيا عن تمديد فتره خفض انتاجها
والبالغ 500 الف برميل يوميا حتى نهايه
هذا العام ليصبح اجمالي الخفض من تسع دول
في اوبك بلاس مليون
و660 الف برميل يوميا حتى نهايه هذه السنه
المزيد من التفاصيل في هذا التقرير
قاده السعوديه خفضا نوعيا منسقا للانتاج
النفطي من دول داخل اوبيك ومن خارجها
باجمالي مليون و660 الف برميل يوميا بدءا
من مايو المقبل وحتى نهايه العام الجاري
وفسرت الخطوه بانها اجراء احترازي لتحقيق
الاستقرار والتوازن في اسواق الخام وفي
التفاصيل ستخفض السعوديه انتاجها من النفط
بخمسمائه الف برميل يوميا فيما ستخفض
الامارات الانتاج ب 144 الف برميل يوميا
والكويت ب128 الف برميل يوميا كما اعلنت
الجزائر خفضا طوعيا بثمانيه واربعين الف
برميل يوميا كذلك اعلن العراق انه سيخفض
الانتاج ب 211,000 برميل يوميا فيما اعلنت
سلطنه عمان خفضا باربعين الف برميل يوميا
كذلك اعلنت كازاخستان عن خفض بانتاجها
بنحو 78 الف برميل يوميا فيما اعلنت
الجابون عن خفض بثمانيه الاف برميل يوميا
وفي موسكو اعلن نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي
الكسندر نوفاك ان بلاده ستمدد خفضا نوعيا
بانتاجها من النفط بواقع 500 الف برميل
يوميا حتى نهايه العمل جاري من متوسط
مستوى الانتاج وفقا لتقييمات مصادر ثانويه
لشهر فبراير
وسيضاف هذا الخفض الى الخفض الذي اعلنه
تحالف اوبيكلاس في اكتوبر 2022 والذي قضى
بخفض بمليوني برميل يوميا حتى نهايه العام
الجاري هذا وكانت اسعار النفط قد تراجعت
الشهر الماضي الى ادنى مستوى لها في 15
شهرا بالقرب من 70 دولار للبرميل وصفه
ازمه المصارف الامريكيه وتدخل الحكومه
السويسريه لانقاذ كريدي سويس العربيه
طبعا مشاهدينا ياتي او تاتي مجموعه
القرارات هذه بعد عده اسابيع وعده اشهر من
التقلبات الحاده في اسعار النفط بغض النظر
ما اذا كنا قد شهدنا انخفاض في اسعار
النفط ام ارتفاع الا انه التقلبات الحاده
في الفتره الاخيره فعلا كانت حددت تثير
الحذر والحيطه وبالتالي دفعت السعوديه
واوبك بلس لاتخاذ هذه التخفيضات
الاحترازيه والوقائيه في ظل الغموض الذي
يكتفي الافق الاقتصادي خاصه في ظل الازمه
المصرفيه التي ضربت عددا من المصارف في
الولايات المتحده وفي اوروبا مؤخرا ما وضع
البنوك المركزيه في حيره هل تستمر في
تجديد السياسه النقديه ام تخفف السياسه
النقديه لحمايه استقرار المنظومه المصرفيه
هذا اداء طبعا الش
لاسعار النفط على مدار الشهر مارس الماضي
ايضا لاحظوا مشاهدينا التقلبات الحاده
التي شهدناها على مدار الربع الاول من هذا
العام برنت على مدار الربع الاول يتراجع
بسبعه في المئه طبعا تحرك في نطاقات تفوق
12 دولار خلال هذه الفتره وهو نطاق مرتفع
جدا من التذبذبات وهو ما حدا باوبك بلس
لاخذ زمام المبادره في الاسواق
وارشاد الاسواق واعطاء السوق الجايدنس
والارشاد التي تحتاجها
لتخفيف الغموض والضبابيه في السوق النفطيه
الاتيه طبعا بسبب العوامل
الاقتصاديه الكليه وايضا العوامل مؤخرا
المصرفيه
للمزيد حول قرارات الخفض الطوعي لانتاج
النفط ينضم الينا مباشره من الخبر نايف
الدندني خبير استراتيجيات الطاقه نايف
اهلا بك شكرا لانضمامك الينا بدايه
يعني في 12 12 دقيقه ثمانيه اعلانات عن
تخفيضات انتاج طوعيه
الشكل هذا الاعلان
يعطينا دلاله على مدى التنسيق والتوافق
بين اعضاء
في ظل الظروف الراهنه وفي اللحظه الراهنه
بالتاكيد
على اعلى المستويات
والاعلانات يعني صدر اتباعا بشكل يوحي انه
تم التنسيق مسبقا وانا هذه
التخفيضات تم الاتفاق عليها وفق
وفق حسابات دقيقه وحث
تستطيع
ان تلتزم به
وصدرت
يعني بشكل منسق بالتاكيد وكان هناك في
تنسيق بينهم
توقيت هذا الخفض اذا ما اضيف له طبعا
تمديد الخفض الروسي الذي كان طبعا هذا
الخفض اعلن سابقا لشهر مارس ولكنه ترك
مدته مفتوحه اليوم وبعد اعلان الدول
الثماني تعلن روسيا عن تمديد هذا الخفض
الى نهايه السنه فبالتالي اجمالي الخفض
سيكون مليون و660 الف برميل يوميا اضافيه
تضاف الى الخفض الذي اتخذ في اكتوبر
الماضي ويستمر حتى نهايه
السنه حجم التخفيض
وتوقيته في رايك كيف يخدم استقرار السوق
النفطيه من حيث السعر حقيقه
اذا تذكر ناصر يمكن بلقائنا الاخير كنا
نتكلم عن نقطتين مهمات يعني احنا في
اللقاء كنا نتكلم عن موضوع روسيا وكيف انه
روسيا حتى مع اعلانها في فبراير الماضي
بتخفيض نصف مليون برميل يوميا على اساس
انه ياخذ حيز التنفيذ في
ما اثر لاسباب كثيره طبعا لسبب انه
استهلاك المحلي الروسي قل وبالتالي روسيا
اضافت
الخفض في الاستهلاك المحلي الى باقه
انتاجها في الاسواق العالميه وبالتالي
روسيا اعلانها لخمس مئه الف برميل في مارس
الحقيقه ما كان مؤثر ولم ياتي يعني حتى
بما يعني بالنتيجه التي تريدها روسيا
نفسها هذا سبب سبب ثاني
امتناع الاداره الامريكيه ايضا عن انه
يعني حتى شراء من
شراء النفط حتى تعبي مخزوناتها
الاستراتيجيه هذا اعطاء انديكيشن ان هناك
من يحاول ان يفعل او او يضغط على الاسواق
بشكل كبير
وهذا الحقيقه امتناحه عن ملء او المخزونات
الاستراتيجيه
مؤشر لما تستهدف الاداره الامريكيه في
موضوع الاسواق في النفط سبب ثالث احنا في
ضبابيه عاليه مثل ما تكلمنا حتى في اللقاء
الاخير لانه ما في احد قادر يتنبه لا في
الانترست ولا في موضوع الازمه المصرفيه
والمشهد ضبابي في انفصال ما بين السوق
النفطيه
الماديه وسوق
التداولات فيبر ماركت نعم ففي انفصال كبير
واحنا شفنا
الديسك تو هذا الانفصال جالس يضغط على
الاسعار بشكل هائل في الدول في اوبك بلس
لا تستطيع ان تتحمل مثل هذا لفتره طويله
خصوصا انه السوق المادي
بموضوع الطلب ما في تهديد حقيقي على
الطالب ولا في زياده في العرض فبالتالي
هذا سيجلب يعني سيعزز الاتصال اكثر ما بين
السوق الماديه والسوق يعني انت ذكرتها
نايف يعني هناك
ارتباك في السوق
والمتمثل في التقلب الحاد في اسعار النفط
المستفيد منه بشكل اكبر هم المضاربون في
اسواق النفط وكنا قد سمعنا سابقا تحذيرات
من وزير الطاقه السعودي بانه على
المضاربين ان ينتبهوا
وانس والسعوديه دائما مستعدين لمفاجاه
هؤلاء بقرارات
تثنيهم عن هذه المضاربه التي تضر باستقرار
السوق النفطيه التي تضر بمصلحه المنتجين
والمستهلكين على حد سواء الى اي درجه
تعتقد بانه عنصر المفاجاه حاضر بقوه في
قرار اليوم
والله يعني هذا اثبات اضافي الحقيقه اللي
ما هو مؤكد في في
تصريحات سمو وزير الطاقه السعودي
سمو ذكر في اكثر من مره انه لا احد يستطيع
ان يتنبا بما قد نفعله ومن يعني من يعتقد
انه قد يقرا يعني ما قد يعني نقرره فهو
مخطئ والحقيقه هذا اثبات اللي بقوله سمو
وزير الطاقه الحقيقيه كان عنصر المفاجاه
كبير
وتوكيته الحقيقه في مرحله حرجه ومرحله
فيها ضبابيه عاليه والمفترض انه هذه
القرار سياتي يعني
باستقرار اكبر
النقديه بعد ما تفتتح الاسواق عن انتظرها
يوم يوم غد المفترض انه تفتح الاسواق
على هذه الاخبار من ثمن دول التخفيضات
هائله بمعدل 1.6
شكرا جزيلا لك نايف الدندني خبير
استراتيجيات الطاقه مباشره معنا من الخبر
اهلا بك
مشاهدينا هنا فقط ننوه في نهايه المطاف
حول التمديد التخفيض في الانتاج الروسي
سابقا كانت روسيا قد اعلنت خفض انتاجها ب
500 الف برميل يوميا خلال شهر مارس من
مستويات العشره ملايين برميل يوميا الملفت
في الاعلان الاخير بانه روسيا
تتعهد
باستمرار وتمديد العمل بالتخفيض في
انتاجها البالغ 500 الف برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه السنه ولكن ليس من مستوى العشره
مليون برميل يوميا ولكن من مستوى اقل بحسب
ما اتفق عليه مع باقي اعضاء اوبك بلس وهو
معدل المصادر الثانويه
لانتاج روسيا خلال شهر فبراير الماضي
والبالغ تسعه ملايين
و830 الف برميل يوميا فبالتالي حجم
التخفيض الروسي سي يكون اكبر فعليا في
السوق النفطيه ليس فقط تمديد فتره التخفيض
ولكن حجم التخفيض سيكون من مستوى اساس اقل
وبالتالي هذا يعطينا المليون وستمائه
وستين الف برميل يوميا اجمال التخفيضات من
الدول الثمان التي اعلنت في 12 دقيقه عن
تخفيضات انتاج طوعيه يضاف لها بطبيعه
الحال تمديد خفض الانتاج الروسي حتى نهايه
العام وجمعنا بانتظار افتتاح سوق النفط
صباح غدا في تداولات اسيا لنرى كيف
ستتعامل السوق النفطيه نعود الان مشاهدينا
بعد نهايه فقرتنا الخاصه التي غطينا فيها
قرارات خفض انتاج النفط من دول اوبك بلس
الى جانب روسيا نعود الان من جديد الى
زميلي صهيب بالفعل سنرى اثر هذه القرارات
ناصر طبعا بعد تقلبات مؤشر الاسعار كما
تبعنا معك على مدار الفتره الماضيه سنرى
غدا كيف سيكون شكل السوق بعد هذه القرارات
المهمه
[موسيقى]
اعلنا تسلطات الروسيه مقتل شخص واصابه نحو
25 بعد انفجار في مقهى بسامبه كان يملكه
قائد فاجنر بحسب اعلام الروسي واوضحت
السلطاتنا تفجير استهدف المراسله الحربيه
التابع
لفاجنرزكي واشارت الى ان التفجير تم عبر
زرع عبوه الناسفه في تمثال سلمه احد
الحاضرين حيث اقيمت حفله للمراسل الحربي
في المقهى ويعتبر فلادينا تاتاسكي احد
ابرز المدونين عن العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا وقبل قليل اعلنت
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه نفيها الضلوع في هذا
التفجير تفجير المقهى في
[موسيقى]
والى ملفنا التالي في التاسعه هذا المساء
العالم يترقب عاصفه ترامب بعد غدنا
الثلاثاء ومدينه نيويورك مشاهدينا التي
توصف بالعاصمه الثقافيه والاقتصاديه
للعالم تتاهب امنيا وتضع سته وثلاثين الف
شرطي وتسعه عشر الف عنصر مدني قبيله مثول
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب اذا
امام المحكمه لابلاغه بتوجيه التهم
الجنائيه اليه في قضيه دفع اموال لنجمه
افلام اباحيه لشراء صمتها محيط المحكمه
تحول الى نقطه شبه مغلقه والفريق الامني
والمكلف بحمايه ترامب ينسق مع السلطات
عمليه الوصول الى قاعه المحكمه والطرق
التي سيسلكها قادما من برج ترامب حيث
سيبيت ليلته فيه بعد وصوله من اما العاصمه
الامريكيه واشنطن فتتحضر امنيا ايضا
لمواجهه العاصفه السياسيه رغم دخول
الكونجرس بمجلسيها الشيوخ والنواب في عطله
لمده بمناسبه عيد الفصح هذا المشهد
مشاهدينا يبعث برساله مروعه للعالم تتعلق
بالانتقام اكثر مما تتعلق بالعداله كما
يقول الحزب الجمهوري على لساني نائب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق
سفيره الولايات المتحده السابقه في الامم
المتحده التي اعلنت رسميا ترشحها للفوز
بترشيح حزبها لانتخابات
2024 الامر ابعد من ذلك ايضا توجيهه
الاتهام من شانه تصميم السباق القادم الى
البيت الابيض تقول صحيفه تايمز البريطانيه
التي اعتبرت ان محاكمه ترامب تشكل سابقه
يحتمل ان تكون خطره للرؤساء المتقاعدين
بمن فيهم الرئيس جو بايدن الذي قد يجد
نفسه ضحيه لتصفيه حسابات قانونيه ايضا
وبالنسبه لترامب ستكون المخاطر شديده ولن
تقتصر على حريته فحسب بل مصيره السياسي
الذي بات على المحك لكن المعركه السياسيه
مش اهدينا التي اندلعت بعد لائحه الاتهام
ضد ترامب ستختبر اخلاص واشنطن لمبدا
العداله والقانون بمعنى انه لا يوجد احد
فوق القانون تختم صحيفه الطعامس
[موسيقى]
محامي الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب قال انه
لا يعرف ما يمكن توقعه عندما يستدعى
الرئيس السابق يوم الثلاثاء الى المحكمه
عن ردتي فعل ترامب وما يتوقع منه في
التقرير التالي
رده فعل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب كانت حديثه من حوله فكيف كان وقع
لائحه الاتهام الجنائيه على ترامب
منهم من قال بان ترامب كان منزعجا وغاضبا
ومصدوما ومنهم من قال بانه ظل هادئا جدا
ورزينا وفقا لواشنطنبوست
الرئيس الامريكي السابق بحسب مصادر مقربه
تبلغ الخبر بمكالمه هاتفيه ثم بدا بالتحرك
اتصالات بالجمهوريين في الكونجرس ووعود
بالمحاربه حتى البراءه والدفع بالمظلوميه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق سيمثل امام محكمه
منهات يوم الثلاثاء القادم قبل ان يضطر
للوقوف امام قاض للاستماع الى التهم
الجنائيه الموجهه اليه تحت حمايه امنيه
مشدده وسط توقعات من احد مستشاريه بان
يظهر الرئيس السابق دقيقا وحذرا خاصه وان
هذه تعد سابقه سياسيه وتاريخيه قد يستفيد
منها ترامب كثيرا ويستغلها في حملته
الانتخابيه للعام 2024
عندما يسلم ترامب نفسه سيتم حجزه في
الغالب مثل اي شخص اخر يواجه التهم ستؤخذ
بصماته من دون تقييد يديه ربما وسيتمتع
بحمايه الخدمه السريه ومن شبه المؤكد انه
سيطلق سراحه في اليوم نفسه
الفريق القانوني الترامب وفريق حملته
امضوا اسابيع في التحضير لصدور لائحه
الاتهام ضده بحثوا خلالها خطه الهجوم
باستخدام ورقه الدوافع السياسيه ضد مدعي
عام مقاطعه من هاتن ومحاميه السابق وهو
احد الشهود الرئيسيين في القضيه
ونداءات لجمع التبرعات والحلفاء
القانونيين والسياسيين والاعلاميين
الى نيويورك من هناك معنى مراسل العربيه
طلال الحاج طلال اهلا بك ما الذي تتحضر له
نيويورك يوم مثول ترامب امام المحكمه
بالفعل ما تراه اليوم هنا في من هاته هو
الهدوء الذي سيسبق العاصفه يوم الثلاثاء
القادم حيث نتوقع مظاهرات صاخبه
يمينيه متطرفه في الكونغرس الامريكي دعت
جميع مؤيدي ترامب الى القدوم هنا الى هذه
الحديقه التي تقع امام مبنى مقر المحكمه
العليا في منهج الى التظاهر
ويخشى الشرطه هنا ويخشى البوليس صراحه يوم
عاصفا هنا
هل هناك مخاطر حقيقيه ان تكون هذه
التظاهرات عنيفه ام هي فقط مبالغه لانه
الامر يتعلق بانصار ترامب
في واقع الامر هناك احتياطات امنيه كبيره
هناك معدات لكشف الاسلحه
مع المتظاهرين هناك عدد كبير ثلاثين الف
شرطي في نيويورك نيويورك للجهاز الاكبر
للشرطه في الولايات المتحده برمتها كلهم
يعملون لا توجد اجازات
اكثر من تسعه اشهر الف الشرطه السريه
والشرطه مكتب التحقيق الفيدرالي ستكون هذه
المنطقه ملغمه بالشرطه بكاميرات التصوير
الاضافيه التي قاموا بتركيبها في كل مكان
عمليه امنيه عاليه رئيسه يصل الى هنا ليله
الاثنين قادمه من حيث يسكن على الخاصه
وفي فلوريدا وسيتوجه الى في واقع الامر
الى ترامب تاور في شارع الخامس لقضاء
الليله سياتي الى هنا كما نفهم الان
الساعه الحاديه عشره صباحا
اي الساعه 16
ولكن طلال عذرا على
المقاطعه طلال اذا كنت تسمعني نعلم ان
اللائحه التهم الموجهه الى ترامب هي
مختومه بالشمع الاحمر
وستتلى وسيكشف عنها من طرف القاضي يوم
وصول ترامب امام المحكمه امام القاضي ولكن
اعلم ان لديك الكثير من المصادر هل تسرب
اي شيء من التهم التي ستوجه لترامب
في الواقع الامر قالوا ان هناك 30 تهمه
ستوجه الى الرئيس ترامب رئيس السابق
ولكن كما نفهم اليوم من مصادرنا ان هناك
فواقع الامر
34 تهمه ستوجه اليه صباح او بعد الظهر يوم
الثلاثاء هذه التهم مختومه بالشمع الاحمر
لا يعرفها احد سوى القاضي والادعاء وسيقوم
القاضي بكشف عنها
ويعرض على ترامب قراءتها له بالتفصيل
وسيعطي نسخ من هذه التهم الى المحامي
ترامب لكن 34 تهمه طلال عدد كبير لا
نعم نعم عدد كبير وكلها متصله بعمليه
الرشا او الرشاوي التي قدمها ترامب الى
من خلال محاميه
ونرى ماذا سيحصل لن يحصل شيئا الكثير
سنبقى في المتابعه معك لانه هي هي ساعات
عاصفه كما وصفتها طلال في نيويورك وايضا
في العاصمه واشنطن وصولا الى وصول الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه شكرا
جزيلا لك طلال الحاج مباشره
وفي خضم مشاهدينا هذه المشاكل القانونيه
التي يتعرض لها الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب والتي قد تؤدي به الى السجن
تطرح تساؤلات حول مائده حكم عليه بالسجن
هل سيكون بامكانه خوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
القادمه من خلف القضبان
نعم يمكن ان يخوض السباق الانتخابيه من
خلف القطبان
وهناك سابقه تعود للجزء الاول من القرن
العشرين
يجين فيكتور السجين رقم
سياسي من الحزب الاشتراكي الامريكي
ترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه خمس مرات منذ
عام 19
[موسيقى]
لقد نظام التجنيد الاجباري خلال الحرب
العالميه الاولى فسجن
ولكنه ترشح لانتخابات 1920
حاز على اكثر من 913 الف صوت
وكان هذا اكثر عدد اصوات حصل عليها في
مسيرته السياسيه
لكنه لم يفز بالانتخابات ولم يصبح رئيسا
قبل
[موسيقى]
رئاسي في ديسمبر عام 1921
معنى من واشنطن طارق الشامي المحلل
السياسي
صحيح في نيويورك ولكن المعركه الاهم في
واشنطن العاصمه هل في حال ادانه ترامب
سيمنع من الترشح الى الانتخابات الرئاسيه
في 2024
لا لا لن يمنع لانه القانون الامريكي لا
يضع ذلك في شروط المرشحين هناك فقط ثلاثه
شروط الاول ان يكون مولودا في الولايات
المتحده والثانيه ان يكون قد عاش في
الولايات المتحده 14 عاما اما الثالث فهو
انه
الرئيس يجب ان يكون على الاقل عمره 35
عاما ليس هناك اي سقف اخر يمكن وضعه
وبالتالي حتى لو ادين او اعتقل او كان في
السجن هذا لا يمنعه من الترشح حتى لو فاز
في الانتخابات فهذا يعني انه يمكن ان يدير
العمليه الرئاسيه من داخل السجن لكن
بالطبع هناك كانت هناك مذكرات قانونيه
صدرت حينما
واجه نيكسون تحريف الملفات لم تصل الى حد
الاتهامات في فضيحه ووتر جيت لكنه وزاره
العدل قالت انه لا يمكن للرئيس ان يمارس
سلطته
وهذه في كل الاحوال لن يمنع من الترشح
ولكن هل هذه الاتهامات وهذه الضجه خاصه ان
هناك اتهام الان من عارضه ازياء اخرى كذلك
في نفس السياق هل هذا يؤثر على مستقبل
السياسي ام كما يقول المدافعون عن ترامب
بانه بالعكس هذا يفيده انتخابيه
يعني حتى الان المشهد واضح جدا وهو ان
الرئيس ترامب استفاد جيدا من هذه العمليه
لانه كان هناك يعني دعم كبير من حتى من
خصومه المنافسين له في الانتخابات مثل
نيكي هيلي وبومبيو وكذلك رونديس وهو اهم
خصم بالنسبه اليه جميعهم وصف المدعي العام
في نيويوركا بانه مسيس وهذه اتهامات وهي
وما الى ذلك هذا ايضا ساعده ماليا هو جمع
وفقا لفاقس نيوز خلال يومين فقط خمسه
ملايين دولار ربع ملايين من مانحين لم يكن
معروفا ان هناك مانحين بمعنى انها مؤسسات
او رجال اثرياء يدعمونه وهؤلاء جميعا
دعموا وبالتالي هناك دعم كبير حصل عليه
واعتقد انه حتى في يوم الثلاثاء حينما يقف
امام القضاء سوف يكون هناك حشد كبير لانه
سعى الى ذلك ترامب يحب ذلك ويحب ان يظهر
للجميع انه ما زال يتمتع بشعبيه كبيره وهو
عطفا على ما ذكرت يعني تصريحات محاميه
ترامب دعم متابع هذا التصريح لمحامي ونعود
للنقاش محامي الرئيس الامريكي السابق ايضا
اكد ان ترامب يتعرض لاضطهاد سياسي كما اكد
على انهم مستعدون لمواجهه التحديات نستمع
لما قال
انه يستعد للمعركه وما يحدث من الواضح انه
اضطهاد سياسي واظن ان الناس يعتقدون ذلك
انها اساءه استخدام كامله للسلطه انه رجل
قوي وهو شخص سيكون مستعدا لهذه المعركه
نحن كذلك مستعد وانا اتطلع للعمل على
تبرئته باسرع وقت
هل توافق المحامي تاكوفينا عندما يقول بان
القضيه برمتها اضطهاد سياسي
يعني ما يجعل الجمهوريين والمحافظين بشكل
عام يعتقدون ذلك هو انه ترامب مرشح رئاسي
لانه لم يحدث من قبل مع اي رئيس سابق انه
واجه كل هذه
المحاكمات والاتهامات من قبل اشخاص واطراف
متعددين في وقت واحد
سوى الرئيس ترامب وترئيس ترامب لانه كان
مصرا على انه سوف يقود هذه الانتخابات وهو
يقول انه لم يخسر الانتخابات السابقه بصرف
النظر عن مدى صدق في ذلك ام لا الا انه في
النهايه هو مرشح رئاسي وكثيرون يشككون في
النوايا خصوصا وان المدعي العام هو
ديمقراطي يعني ليس ليس عضوا وانما هو
انتخب بصفه ديمقراطيا المدعي العام ينتخب
في الولايات المتحده في الولايات وبالتالي
هو هذا احد الاسباب التي تثير الشكوك ومن
قبله ايضا كان المدعي الذي كان يشرف على
يعني فيما تبقى من وقت رجاء ما
السيناريوهات التي تتوقعها يوم الثلاثاء
بعد مثول ترامب امام القاضي
يعتقد انه سوف تمر بسلام لانه هناك اتفاق
تم بين محامي ترامب وبين الادعاء العام
هناك في نيويورك وسوف فقط يقوم بالاجراءات
من المتوقع ان يعني لا يعترف بالذنب
الرئيس ترامب وسيقول انها اتهاماتها هي
وباطله وسوف تكون هناك بعد ذلك سلسله من
الطعون القضائيه وهناك محاولات لنقل
القضيه من نيويورك اصلا
طيب ايضا
نعملك دعوه التاسعه هذا المساء طارق شاميه
مباشره من واشنطن العاصمه
[موسيقى]
التاسع مستمره فيها بعد فاصل
قلق عالمي من تحول فيروس الى جائحه جديده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد فيروس قديم جديد عمره
اكثر من خمسه عقود وصفته الصحه العالميه
بالمرض الفتاكه هذا الفيروس ليس له علاج
ويقتل نحو 90% من المصابين به مما دفع
منظمه الصحه العالميه الى دق ناقوس الخطر
قبل ان يتحول الى جائحه عالميه بعد ان
تفشى في دولتين افريقيتين هما غينيا
وتنزانيا المنظمه الامميه عقدت اجتماعا
عاجلا بشان وجمعت خبراء الصحه من جميع
انحاء العالم لمناقشه سبل تطوير لقاحات او
علاجات قبل ان يعود العالم لمشهد كورونا
المرعب اما اعراض الفيروس فهي شبيهه
باعراض الانفلونزا لكنها قاتله بعد ايام
فقط من الاصابه به وينتمي الى عائله
فايروس ايبولا الخطير
مشاهدينا لا ينتقل عبر الهواء وينتشر
بسرعه من خلال الاتصال المباشر بين البشر
خاصه المرتبطين بالسوائل مثل الدم او
اللعاب ويمكن حتى لجثث المصابين ان تبقى
معديه عند الدفن خبراء الصحه يوضحون ان
الوقايه بشكل عام من الحمى النزفيه
المرتبطه بالفيروسات مثل ماربورج او
الايبولا قد تكون امرا صعبا ويجب استخدامه
وسائل الحمايه مثل ارتداء القفازات
والاقنعه وطرد الحشرات والقوارض هذا الامر
دفع بالدول العربيه مثل السعوديه
والامارات والكويت وعمان بتوصيه مواطنيها
بتاجيل السفر في الوقت الحالي الى كل من
تنزانيا وغينيا الاستوائيه
[موسيقى]
الذكاء الاصطناعي قد يتسبب بثناء البشريه
تحذير جديد من خطر تطوره وفق ما كشفه
مؤسسوا معهد ابحاث ذكاء الاله لصحيفه
البريطانيه الذكاء الاصطناعي لا يبقى
مقيدا داخل اجهزه الكمبيوتر لفتره طويله
بل من الممكن ان يقوم بارسال سلاسل الحمض
النووي بالبريد الالكتروني الى المعامل
لانتاج بروتينات ستسمح له بتطوير حياه
صناعيه والخروج الى العالم مما سيؤدي الى
انقراض البشريه ولاجل ذلك يجب حظر تطويرها
ومعاقبه ما ينتهك هذا الحظر بقسوه واوضحت
الصحيفه ان الرساله التي دعت جميع مختبرات
التكنولوجيا الى التوقف لمده سته اشهر على
الاقل عن تدريب انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي
وتحديدا كانت تطالب بحلول ضعيفه جدا
للمشكله التي يتسبب فيها التطور السريع
وغير المنضبط للذكاء الاصطناعي بدورها
اعلنت السلطات الايطاليه حضره روبوت
المحادثه قرارها
بعدم احترام البرنامج للتشريعات المتعلقه
بالبيانات الشخصيه
[موسيقى]
تشهد مكه المكرمه خلال شهر رمضان توافد
اعداد كبيره من المعتمرين من مختلف انحاء
العالم وسطى توقعات بارتفاع مؤشرات
الايواء والفنادق في مكه المكرمه خلال هذه
الفتره بنحو مئه في المئه نظرا لتزايد
اعداد الزوار والمعتبرين الذين يتوافدون
على مكه المكرمه وتحتضن مكه المكرمه اكثر
من الف فندق واكثر من 250 الف غرفه فندقيه
بتصنيف عالي الجوده اذا وحسب المواصفات
العالميه وهي جاهزه لاستقبال المعتبرين
المعتمرين وكذلك جميع هذه الفنادق ملتزمه
وتقوم بعمليه التنظيف والتعقيم لكافه
المرافق على مدار الساعه
مباشره من الحرم المكي معنا اسامه القاسم
مراسل العربيه اسامه من خلفك يعني حشود
كبيره من المعتمرين في الشهر الفضيل هل
لدينا بدايه اي ارقام او احصائيات عن
اعداد ضيوف الرحمن على الاقل في العشر
الاوائل من رمضان
[موسيقى]
اهلا صهيب تحيه طيبه لكم ولجميع مشاهدي
قناه العربيه وطاب مسائكم بكل خير نعم
بالامس رئاسه شؤون الحرمين اعلنت عن وصول
اكثر من 9.4 مليون زائر ومعتمر الحرم
المكي خلال العشر الاوائل وبالتاكيد ان
هذه الاعداد سوف تتضاعف مع الايام القادمه
حتى انتهاء شهر رمضان المبارك طبعا
الرئاسه شؤون الحرمين بالتعاون مع عدد من
الجهات تقدم الخدمات الكبيره جدا للزوار
والمعتمرين داخل اروقه المسجد الحرام ايضا
بمساحه البارح كان هناك اكثر من 12 مليون
لتر من سقيا زمزم تم توزيعها وايضا اكثر
من زائر ومعتمر للمسجد الحرام طبعا هذه
الصوره التي نشاهدها الان هي اثناء اداء
صلاه التراويح في مسجد الحرام والتي
نشاهدها الان في التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه
وساحات التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه ايضا
بالامس تم اعلان استكمال تهيئه جميع مرافق
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه بما فيها
الساحات والاسطح كذلك ونعم صهيب ايضا
اليوم تشهد امتلاء بالكامل هناك اكثر من
الفندق في مكه المكرمه باكثر من 250 الف
وحده سكنيه وترتكز هذه الفنادق في الششه
العزيزيه ومحبس الجن وايضا المسفله التي
الان هي ممتلئه بالكامل ولكن اسامه هذا
المشهد الذي كنا نتابعه الان للمصلين وهم
يؤدون صلاه التراويح هذه الاعداد الغفيره
كيف يتم تسيير خروجهم بعد اتمام الصلاه
يعني اعداد كبيره جدا كيف يتم تفادي وقوع
الازدحامات
[موسيقى]
نعم صحيح كل هذه الاعداد التي نشاهدها
الان وكل هذه الحشود يتم اخراجها او
ادخالها بطريقه معينه من خلال توفير عدد
من الكوادر الامنيه المدنيه وايضا عدد من
المترجمين لارشاد التائهين وايضا الجهات
الامنيه المشاركه كامن الحج والعمره
والامن العام طبعا هناك طريقه دائما تحصل
في شهر رمضان المبارك هي ان كل توسعه وكل
ساحه لها مدخل ولها مخرج هذه المداخل
والمخارج تقلق وقت الصلاه لاداء الصلوات
سواء صلاه التراويح او الصلوات الاخرى
وتفتح بعد انتهاء الصلوات ويكون هناك حركه
تردديه
والخروج الجدير بالذكر ايضا ان هناك اربع
محطات متواجده حول الحرم المكي لايصال
الزوار والمعتمرين الى فنادقهم والاتيان
بهم ايضا الى الحرم اسامه اكثر من تسعه
ملايين
مكه المكرمه في العشر الاوائل من رمضان ما
هي التوقعات للعشر الاواخر التي تحظى
بقدسيه كبيره لدى المسلمين
[موسيقى]
نعم صهيب بالتاكيد العشر الاواخر تحظى
بهذه القدسيه الكبيره جدا نتحدث عن
بالتاكيد ان هناك ستكون اعداد كبيره لم
نصل الى احصائيه معينه ولكن بالتاكيد انها
ستكون ضعف ما احصيه خلال العشر الاولى
العشر الاواخر ايضا هناك خطط مختلفه
بالنسبه للتنظيم لكثره الحشود وكثره
الزوار والمعتمرين وايضا ان الحركه تكون
مرتكزه بشكل كبير جدا حول مساحه المطاف
والمسحب وتاكد سيكون هناك تركيز اعلى من
خلال تفويج واداره حشود زوار ومعتمرين
المسجد الحرام الفنادق ممتلئه الان هل
سيكون هناك مساحه مثلا في الايام القادمه
يعني هذا ما سيكون ايضا سنعلمه في الايام
القادمه الصهيب هناك اكثر من 300 شركه
لاداء العمره مجهزه بالكامل هي بالتاكيد
انها تسعى ايضا انها تعمل موازنه وتحاول
انها ما تكون في ازدحام في خلال هذه شكرا
من الايام القادمه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
الصوره الحيه مباشره من الحرم المكي
الشريف اسامه القاسم مراسل العربيه
[موسيقى]
من احياء الحجاز والشام الى خنادق الرصاص
والموت خلال الحرب العالميه الاولى يتناول
مسلسل سفر بارليك ما ارتكبته الدوله
العثمانيه بحق اهل شبه الجزيره العربيه
وتجنيد الالزامي للشبان العرب دراما
اجتماعيه تاريخيه لا يغيب عنها الطابع
الرومانسي ضمن القصه اخر مشروع حضر له
المخرج الراحل حاتم علي قبيله وفاته وهو
من اخراج الليث حجو وتوزعت البطوله بين
نجوم من السعوديه وسوريا ولبنان والعالم
العربي المزيد في تقرير الدراما مع سهى
واعداد ايام القاسم
[موسيقى]
تعرفوا ايش يسمون دولتك في اوروبا
الرجل المريض
كل الحين قاعد انتظره يموت
الكل مجتمع يبغى يسقط دوله الاسلام بعد
نهود
[موسيقى]
هذا هو مسلسل سفر اللي كان مفاجاه الموسم
الدرامي الرمضاني الضخمه عن كارثه التهجير
الجماعي القسري اللي طبقتها الدوله
العثمانيه عام
1915 تجاه الالاف من الرجال والنساء
والاطفال من سكان المدينه المنوره حدث
تاريخي كان من المهم جدا للدراما ان
تتناولوا يوما هذا حدث
له قيمته التاريخيه وايضا قيمته الانسانيه
ويعتبر اليوم وكانه جريمه حرب لانه تم
تهزيرها هذه المدينه حتى قيل في كثير من
مصادر التاريخيه انه لم يبقى الا 41 شخص
من اهالي المدينه
يقتلون المدينه المنوره تم تهجيرا بالكامل
الست والجمعيه في السوري يحيى واللبنانيين
فايز وفريد حيث يخوض الاصدقاء الاربعه
رحله الوعي السياسي والانتقال من اروقه
التحصيل العلمي الى جبهات القتال مع الجيش
العثماني اولا في معارك البلقان على
الحدود الروسيه ومن ثم التمرد على ظلم
السلطنه العثمانيه ووحشيه ممارساتها انا
فعلا
حسن في اسطنبول الابنيه التفاصيل
الديكورات المحلات اللبس المترو العربيات
الحنطور التفاصيل التفاصيل التفاصيل جدا
كلها موجوده وكلها موضوعه بعنايه لدرجه
انه فعليا الواحد فينا بيصدقني اسطنبول
بالارز لما صورنا على حدود البلقان كان
كمان شيء كتير حلو لانه عبد الرحمن مثلا
كثير كان بالنسبه له الثلج كثير كبير
وكثير كان الجو حلو هنيك وما حسينا حالنا
يعني انه افترقنا هلا كتير اشتقنا للسات
هون كمان بس مره كان كمان كانت مغامره
لقلنا انا وعبد الرحمن ويحيى
الجمهور كبير هنا بعد التغريدات
[موسيقى]
اذا كان مكتوب على اهل ذي البلاد انهم
يحاربون فارضهم
[موسيقى]
واسعد باستضافه الفنان السعودي القدير
محمد بخشو معنا مباشره من جده استاذ محمد
مساء الخير رمضان كريم اهلا بك
ومبروك المسلسل انت احد الابطال الرئيسيين
في هذا المسلسل بدايه كيف شايف ردود الفعل
على المسلسل حتى الان حتى هذه الحلقات
اولا اسعد الله مساءكم جميعا
وكل عام وانتم بخير وجميع المشاهدين بخير
اولا قبل كل حاجه اوجه الشكر
لقناه ام بي سي
على ما قدمته في هذه السنه من هذا العمل
الجبار انتاج فخم تكلفه عاليه جدا
لوكيشنات مختلفه
ابطال من جميع تقريبا الدول العربيه
خصوصا من الحجاز والشام
ولبنان
العمل فخم جدا لدرجه انه احنا يعني كنا
خايفين لانه طبعا هذا
لمن يكون واحد زي حاتم علي كان يبغى يخرج
العمل هذا
فعليه رحمه الله وندعو له بالرحمه في هذا
الشهر الفضيل
فانا كان اول حاجه حلمي اني انا اشتغل مع
فنان حاتم علي نعم الله يرحمه المخرج
الكبير حاتم علي نعمه الراحل هو الذي بدات
تحضير معكم لهذا المسلسل محمد والان اتمه
المخرج الكبير ايضا لا يستحجه
حدثنا على فتره التحضير مع حاتم علي كم
امتدت
وكذلك
التغير الذي طرا حتى اتمام هذا المسلسل
والله انا اول نص جاني من
الفنان حاتم علي المخرج وهو اللي رشحني
اساسا في هذا العمل
وفجاه دخلت كورونا
فتوقف العمل
بعد ذلك
سمعنا انه توفى رحمه الله بعد كده دخلنا
مع الليت وهو لا يقل
نجوميه عن الفنان حاتم علي وكان بقدر
المسؤوليه
وبحقيقه يعني انا استمتعت بالعمل معك على
ذكر المتعه بالعمل استاذ محمد بخش انت من
المدينه المنوره يعني وسفر برلك يحكي عن
حدث تاريخي مهم قبل 100 عام
التجنيد الاجباري والتهجير الذي حصل في في
المدينه المنوره وقتها ما الذي عناه لك
تجسيد هذا الدور والاناره على تلك يعني
الفتره التاريخيه وهذا الحدث التاريخي
الجميل ان كاحد ابناء المدينه المنوره
ويمكن انا في الطفوله عشت على
على اواخر
الملك سعود رحمه الله تعالى
لكني عشت كثير من قصص وروايات واحداث اسمع
الحكايات نعم معنى الدوله العثمانيه نعم
نعم
وكثير من جيراننا كانوا عثمانيين موجو
ما رحلوا
[موسيقى]
والله والله انا يعني اساسا يعني صراحه
يعني اكون واضح معاك كان الاساس يعني احنا
كنا عاملنا كتبنا فيلم اسمه الحصاد هو
بيتكلم عن سفر بيرليك وكان هذا دعم من
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير فيصل بن سلمان
حفظه الله على انه احنا نعمل هذا العمل
الا هو تحت مسمى الحصار حصار المدينه
تحديدا
وكثير من المشاهد وكثير من الحاجات
الحقيقيه كنت انا اتناقش فيها مع الاستاذ
اللي تحجوا
وكثير من هذا حقيقه هنا رجل كان متفهم جدا
يعني احنا كثير اتكلمنا مثلا في الاسواق
اتكلمنا في محطات القطار اتكلمنا ببعض
الديكورات الموجوده
اتكلمنا ببعض اللهجات والمفردات اللي كانت
موجوده في المدينه
تكلمنا عن الموسيقى عن انواع الموسيقى
اللي كانت هذيك الايام فكثير يعني كان
الاستاذ الليث يعني حقيقه كان اخ وعزيز
ومتفهم جدا وانا استمتعت بهذا العمل بحكم
اني انا حسيت ان انا انا بقدم للمدينه شيء
وهذا كان لابد منه مثل هذه الاعمال حقيقه
يعني احنا نحتاجها تاريخ كثير من الناس
التاريخ استاذ محمد الملاحظ انه هناك خط
سياسي في المسلسل هناك خط تاريخي هناك خط
عاطفي كذلك قصص الحب حاضره في المسلسل
والرومانسيه كذلك الى اي حد طبعا والحضور
العربي المشترك يعني انه فنانين سعوديين
سوريين لبنانيين وعرب كذلك الى اي حد يعني
هذه الخلطه اضافه للانتاج الضخم من ام بي
سي
يؤدي برايك الى نجاح هكذا نوعيه من
المسلسلات
الواقع ان هي دراما
ودراما حملت كل الاوجه الجميله اللي تقدم
لك العمل في القالب هذا الجميل اكيد يعني
المرحله كان فيها الحب وفيها
الحرب والسلام هي سنوات سنوات من الحب
والرحيل هي السنوات من الالم هي سنوات من
داخل هذا الالم كان في الحب كان في صراع
كان في كل شيء موجود احنا احنا اطفال كنا
نحس بهذا الصراع لما كنا نمر من بعد
البيوتات العثمانيه كنا نحس بالفارقه
الكوني بيننا وبينهم يعني نعم حقيقه العمل
جمع كل الحاجات هذه فكون عمل قوي استاذ
محمد انه الشباب اليافع الان يهتم بمعرفه
هذا التاريخ خاصه في السعوديه
او انا حبيت يعني اقول الشيء الجميل في
العمل ده انه نسبه عاليه من المشاركين في
العمل السعوديين ليس الفنانين فقط او
الممثلين لا المكياج الديكور
الكثير يعني انا اعتقد انه سبعين في الميه
كان في سعودي من خلال الاكاديميه
الاكاديميه ام بي سي وهذا شيء جميل جدا
احنا مكسب بالنسبه لينا اننا نكسب هؤلاء
الشباب
بالعكس يعني ايضا كثير من ابنائهم ابنائي
يعني في النهايه ونعتبرهم جميعا كلهم نجوم
اللي شاركوا في هذا العمل
وعلى راسهم كان بطوله
ابني عبد الرحمن اليماني اللي هو انا
اعتبره من
الفنانين المميزين اللي امتلكوا كريزمه
جيده مؤيد الثقافي
مستشار مجدي القاضي كثير كثير من الزهراني
مجموعه من الممثلين كان وا الحقيقه يعني
كانوا قدر المسؤوليه
وتعبوا على العمل تهانينا استاذ محمد نعم
تهانينا وبالتوفيق طبعا على هذا العمل
المميز مسلسل سفر بارليك احد اضخم انتاجات
مجموعه ام بي سي تلفزيونيه الفنان القدير
السعودي محمد بخش كنت معنا من جده شكرا
جزيلا لك على تلبيه دعوه العربيه هذا
المساء
[موسيقى]
خصصت وكاله التفويج واداره الحشود برئاسه
شؤون الحرمين اكثر من 400 موظف ميدني مؤهل
ومدرب على مهام تنظيم دخول وخروج وتنقل
المعتمرين
[موسيقى]
مع دخول شهر رمضان يفيد الى الحرم المكي
اكثر من مليون و200 الف معتمر ومصلي يوميا
بعدها تشغيل الحرم المكي هذا الموسم بكامل
الطاقه الاستيعابيه ما جعل رئاسه الشؤون
الحرمين والقطاعات الامنيه المختصه باداره
الحشود تعمل وفق خطط نوعيه لتبطي عمليات
التدفقات البشريه وادارتها
ليس لخطه واحده الخطه للطوارئ خطه وقت
هطول الامطار خطه الطوارئ وقت زياده
الكثافه العدديه بعد كل صلاه يتم فتح صحن
المطاف مباشره يعني اثناء الصلاه يتم فتح
الحواجز مجرد ما المعتمرين يصلون في الدور
الارضي او في المناطق الخلفيه من الدور
الارضي على طول بعد الصلاه بامكانهم
التوجه مباشره الى صحن المطر اربعه عشر
مسارا بالمسجد الحرام لدخول وخروج
المعتمرين والمصلين وكوادر بشريه مؤهله
تدير المسارات وعمليات التفويج الى صحن
المطاف اضافه الى مراقبه الكثافات عبر
غرفه العمليات والتاكد من ثلاثه التنقل
للمعتمرين اثناء اداء النسك صحن المطاف
الثور الارضي للمعتمرين الدور الاول وسطح
المطاف للمعتمرين والمصلين الساحات
الخارجيه والتوسيعات السعوديه الثالثه
بساحاتها للمصلين هناك فئه من المعتمرين
يرغب في صلاه القيام مثلا او صلاه
التراويح هناك بعض المساحات تم تخصيصها في
صحن المطاف في الدور الارضي في المناطق
الخلفيه
لصلاه المعتمرين خصصت وكاله التفويز
واداره الحشود بالرئاسه العامه اكثر من
400 موظف ميداني مؤهلين ومدربين على مهام
تنظيم دخول وخروج وتنقل المعتمرين
والزائرين داخل المسجد الحرام وذلك عبر
ممرات ومسارات وابواب جهزت لخدمتهم ووفق
معاييره ونسب تراعي الخطط التشغيليه
من الحرم المكي السلطانه السلمي العربيه
وختام التاسعه بالعناوين
دول في بلاس تقرر وخفضا طوعيا باكثر من
مليون و600 الف برميل يوميا
مقتل مراسل حربي واصابه 25 شخصا في
عبوه اسفه في تمثال نيويورك تستعد امنيا
لمحكمه ترامب الثلاثاء والاخير يتحدث علنا
قبل مثوله امام المحكمه سفر بارليك دراما
الحرب والحب تفاصيل تاريخ مقاومه
العثمانيين في الجزيره العربيه
التاسع انتهت ولكن الفتره الاخباريه
المسائيه مستمره على العربيه الان الى 360
مع العائد الينا اذن بعد شهر غياب الف حمد
لله على السلامه
وعكه صحيه الحمد لله معافى دائما واشتقنا
لك كثير احنا وانت وجميع المشاهدين ان شاء
الله شكرا جزيلا
انا كنت على الهواء
حصتك موجوده اكيد شكرا جزيلا شكرا